john kirby and marine corps general
kenneth mckenzie will be making a
statement let's listen then
uh five o'clock um so i will not waste
up any more time uh general can you hear
and see me okay
hey john i can hear and see you just
fine how many of them thank you sir
thanks for being here today and i turn
it over to you sir
thanks john
good afternoon everyone i'm here to
announce the completion of our
withdrawal from afghanistan in the end
of the military mission to evacuate
american citizens
third country nationals and vulnerable
afghans
the last and the last manned aircraft is
now clearing the airspace above
afghanistan
we will soon release a photo of the last
c-17 departing afghanistan with major
general chris donahue and the u.s
ambassador to afghanistan ross wilson
aboard
while the military evacuation is
complete the diplomatic mission to
ensure additional u.s citizens and
eligible afghans who want to leave
continues and i know that you have heard
and i know that you're going to hear
more about that from the state
department shortly
tonight's withdrawal signifies both the
end of the military component of the
evacuation but also the end of the
nearly 20-year mission that began in
afghanistan shortly after september 11
2001.
it's a mission that brought osama bin
laden to a just end along with many of
his al-qaeda co-conspirators and it was
not it was not a cheap mission the cost
was 2461 u.s service members and
civilians killed and more than 20 000
who were injured
sadly that includes 13 u.s service
members who were killed last week by an
isis-k suicide bomber
we honor their sacrifice today as we
remember their heroic accomplishments
no words from me could possibly capture
the full measure of sacrifices
and accomplishments of those who served
nor the emotions they're feeling at this
moment but i will say that i'm proud
that both my son and i have been a part
of it
before i open it up for questions i do
want to provide some important context
to the evacuation mission that we just
completed
in what was the largest non-combatant
evacuation in the u.s military's history
since august the 14th over an 18-day
period u.s military aircraft have
evacuated more than 79 000 civilians
from
hamad karzai international airport that
includes 6 000 americans and more than
73
500 third country nationals and afghan
civilians
this last category includes special
immigrant visas consular staff at-risk
afghans and their families
in total u.s and coalition aircraft
combined to evacuate more than 123 000
civilians
which were all enabled by u.s military
service members who were securing and
operating the airfield
on average we have evacuated more than 7
500 civilians per day over the 18 days
of the mission which includes 16 full
days of evacuations
and more than 19 000 on a single day
these numbers do not include the roughly
5 000 service members and their
equipment that were sent to afghanistan
to secure the airfield and who were
withdrawn at conclusion of our mission
the numbers i provided represent a
monumental accomplishment
but they do not do justice to the
determination the grit the flexibility
and the professionalism of the men and
women of the u.s military and our
coalition partners who were able to
rapidly combine efforts and evacuate so
many under such difficult conditions
as such i think it's important that i
provide you with what i hope will be
some valuable context
when the president directed the complete
withdrawal of u.s forces from
afghanistan in april the team at u.s
central command began to update and
refine our existing plan for a potential
non-combatant evacuation operation or a
neo in afghanistan
we have a framework of plans that
included numerous branches and sequels
depending on the nature of the security
environment
over time we continued to refine our
plans which included the interagency the
international community and other
combatant commands
plans such as this are built upon a
number of facts and assumptions and
facts and assumptions change over time
while observing the security environment
deteriorate we continue to update our
facts and assumptions
as the security situation rapidly
devolved in afghanistan we took a number
of actions to position ourselves for a
potential neo based upon direction from
the secretary of defense
we positioned forces in the region and
put them on increased alert we began to
pre-position supplies and we began some
preparatory work on intermediate
facilities in qatar with the support of
our gracious host nation
when the evacuation was formally
directed on august the 14th we began to
carry out our plan
based upon the initial assumption that
the afghan security forces would be a
willing and able security partner in
kabul defending the capital for a matter
of weeks or at least for a few days
within 24 hours of course the afghan
military collapsed completely opening
kabul up to the taliban's advance
on august the 15th in a meeting with
taliban senior leadership in doha i
delivered a message on behalf of the
president that our mission in kabul was
now the evacuation of americans and our
partners that we would not tolerate
interference and that we would
forcefully defend our forces and the
evacuees if necessary
the taliban's response in that meeting
was in line with what they've said
publicly
while they stated their intent to enter
and occupy kabul they also offered to
work with us on a deconfliction
mechanism to prevent miscalculation
while our forces operated in close
quarters
finally they promised not to interfere
with our withdrawal
it's important to understand that within
48 hours of the neo execution order the
facts on the ground had changed
significantly we had gone from
cooperating on security with a long time
partner and ally
to initiating a pragmatic relationship
of necessity with a long-time enemy
into that environment rear admiral pete
baisley and brigadier general farrell
sullivan of the marines and subsequently
major general chris donahue of the
army's 82nd airborne division deployed
and employed their forces and did
extraordinary work with the leading
elements of our reinforcement package to
safely close the embassy in one period
of darkness or one one evening to
establish a deconfliction mechanism with
the taliban
to establish security at the airport and
to bring in the rest of our
reinforcements into the airport they
accomplished this difficult list of
tasks within 48 hours of supporting the
transfer of the embassy to the airport
i visited kabul on tuesday august the
17th to see the work being done to
establish security firsthand and to
observe the transition to the evacuation
i left on a c-17 that brought more than
130 afghans and american citizens out
from uh karzai international airport to
l ud air base in qatar
our men and women on the ground at the
airport quickly embraced the dangerous
and methodical work of defending the
airport while conducting the
hand-to-hand screening of more than 120
000 evacuees from six different entry
points under the airfield
we also conducted three separate
helicopter extractions of three distinct
groups of civilians including at least
185 american citizens and with our
german partners 21 german citizens
additionally u.s special operations
forces reached out to help break in
bring in more than 1064 american
citizens in 2017 sivs for afghans at
risk and 127 third country nationals all
via phone calls vectors and escorting
we have evacuated more than 6 000 u.s
civilians which we believe represents
the vast majority of those who wanted to
leave at this time it would be difficult
to overestimate the number of unusual
challenges in committing the competing
demands that our forces on the ground
have successfully overcome
the threat to our forces particularly
from isis k
was very real and tragically resulted in
the loss of 13 service members and
dozens of afghan civilians
i've said this before but i'd like to
say it again
we greatly appreciate the contributions
of the many coalition partners that
stood with us on the ground at harma at
the karzai international airport i'm
just going to single out one nation as
an example of the many the norwegians
who maintained their hospital
at the airport and who were absolutely
critical for the immediate care of our
wounded after the abbey gate attack
even after the attack they agreed to
extend the presence of their hospital to
provide more coverage for us
our diplomats have also been with us in
kabul from the beginning and their work
in processing over 120 000 people stands
right beside that of their military
partners we were a team on the ground
as i close my remarks i would like to
offer my personal appreciation to the
more than 800 000 service members and
twenty five thousand civilians who have
served in afghanistan and particularly
to the families of those whose loved
ones have been lost or wounded
your service as well as that of your
comrades and family members will never
be forgotten
my heart is broken over the losses we
sustained three days ago
as the poem by lawrence bennion goes
we will remember them
the last 18 days have been challenging
americans can be proud of the men and
women of the armed forces who met these
challenges head on i'm now ready to take
your questions
thank you general we'll start
with the lead ap i would ask you to
because we're limited on time to please
limit your follow-up so that more people
can get questions asked go ahead later
general thanks for doing this it's leda
with ap um can you give us a sense of
whether or not there were any american
citizens or other civilians who were
taken out on any of those last couple of
c-17s that flew out this aft this
afternoon and can you give us a picture
of what you saw
with equipment and other things getting
either destroyed or removed at the
airport before they left
here later so we no american citizens
came out on the last what we call the
joint tactical exfiltration the last
five jets to leave
we we maintain the ability to bring them
in up until immediately before departure
but we were not able to bring any
americans out that activity ended
probably about 12 hours before our exit
although we continued the outreach and
would have been prepared to to bring
them on until the very last minute but
none of them made it to the airport and
were able to be and were able to be
accommodated
we brought some of it out and we
demilitarized some of it let me give an
example of something that we
demilitarized
but you're uh very much aware of course
of the rocket attack that occurred
yesterday where five rockets were fired
at uh at the airfield our crams were
very effective in uh in engaging the two
rockets that did fall on the airfield
and we believe they probably kept them
from doing more significant damage we
elected to keep those systems in
operation up until the very last minute
it's a complex uh procedure complex and
time intensive procedure to break down
those systems so we demilitarize those
systems so that they'll never be used
again and there was just a we felt it
was more important to protect our forces
than to bring those systems back we have
also d miller demilitarized uh equipment
that we did not bring out at uh
of the airport that included a number of
m-wraps uh up to uh 70 m-raps that we
de-militarize and will never be used
again by anyone 27
humvees a little tactical vehicle that
will never be driven again additionally
uh on the ramp at
hkya are a total of
73 aircraft uh those aircraft will never
fly again uh when we left they'll never
be able to be operated by anyone most of
them are non-mission capable to begin
with but certainly they'll never be able
to be flown again thank you
david
general david martin with cbs
was there any attempt
to interfere
with the
final flights out
either by
the taliban or by
isis or any other group and did
at the end did americans just vacate the
premises or did they
turn it over to the taliban
oh we know that isis k has worked very
very hard to strike us and to continue
to strike us
we feel that the strike we took
yesterday in kabul actually was very
disruptive to their attack plans and
threw him off stride and i think that
was one of the significant reasons why
they were not able to organize
themselves and get after us as we
conducted the final withdrawal i will
tell you the taliban have been very
pregnant very pragmatic and very
business-like as we have approached this
uh withdrawal we did not turn it over to
the taliban uh general donahue one of
the last things he did before leaving
was talk to the taliban commander that
he had been coordinating with as soon as
with about the time we were going to
leave just to let them know that we were
leaving but there was no discussion of
turning anything over
of that at all
jen
general mckinsley jennifer griffin from
fox news
if i could just have you reflect
personally
after 20 years of war you've served
there you've now watched the last troops
leave you've lost troops in recent days
how did it feel
leaving afghanistan to the very group
that you overthrew 20 years ago the
taliban
well as i sort of said in my remarks as
you know i've been there a couple times
my son's been there a couple times um so
and it was very uh i was very conflicted
actually but i would tell you i was
pretty much focused on the task at hand
i'll have days ahead to actually think
about that but there was just so much
going on in this headquarters and we
were so completely focused on getting
our troops out and and in the days
before getting uh you know getting
getting our citizens out and vulnerable
afghans to the best of our ability that
i did not have a lot of time for
reflection i'm sure i will do that in
the future but right now i'm pretty much
consumed with the with the operational
task at hand
that's a good question and i am going to
be thinking about that in the days ahead
your message to americans and afghan
allies who were left behind
so the military phase of this operation
has ended the diplomatic sequel to that
will now begin and i believe our
department of state is going to work
very hard to allow any american citizens
that are left and we think the citizens
that were not brought out number in the
low very low hundreds uh i believe that
we're going to work we're going to be
able to get those people out i think
we're also going to negotiate very hard
and very aggressively to get our other
afghan partners out the military phase
is over but our desire to bring these
people out remains as intense as it was
before the weapons have just shifted if
you will from the military realm to the
diplomatic realm and the department of
state will now take the lead on that
nancy
let me clarify just a couple points can
you tell us how many people are on that
final c-17 flight can you tell us where
that flight is headed
and you mentioned that general donahue
talked to his taliban essentials
essentially his counterpart can you give
us any sense on what role the taliban
played from a security perspective to
allow the u.s to safely depart kabul
yeah so i'm not going to be able to
answer the first two questions because
those operations are still concluding as
to where the those aircraft are going
and the exact disposition of our forces
on the aircraft i can tell you this
though about what the taliban has done
they established a firm perimeter
outside of the airfield to prevent
people from coming on the airfield
during our departure and we've worked
that with them for a number of days they
did not have direct knowledge of our
time of departure we choose to keep that
we chose to keep that very information
very restricted but they were actually
very helpful and useful to us as we
close down operations
i want to go to the phones i haven't
done that yet dan lamoth
hey thanks for thanks for calling me uh
general can you can you give us a i
guess a deeper level of detail on what
this last day looked like in terms of
number of flights number of people you
had on the ground to start with
um who might have been on that last
plane particularly senior leaders and uh
kind of just how it's all played out
thanks sure so let me actually begin
with the back end of your question on
the last airplane out was uh general
chris donahue the commander of the 82nd
airborne division and my ground force
commander there and he was accompanied
by our charge a ambassador ross wilson
so they came out together so the state
uh defense team came out on the last
aircraft and were in fact the last
people to stand on the ground step on
the airplane so what has happened over
the last 12 or 18 hours is
we first of all we were intent on
maintaining the ability to bring out
americans and other and other afghans as
long as we could so we kept that
capability until just a few hours ago
and we were able to bring out some
people earlier in the day although as
i've noted earlier we had to cut it off
sometime before this operation began but
we were intent on maintaining that
capability we were also intent on
maintaining our force protection because
the the threats from isis were very real
uh very uh very concerning and so we did
a number of things we had overwhelming
u.s air power overhead should there been
any uh challenge to our departure and
again there was absolutely no question
we were not going to be challenged by
the taliban we were if we're going to be
challenged it was going to be by isis
and i think some of the things we've
done yesterday particularly the strike
and other things we've done have
disrupted their ability to conduct that
to conduct that attack planning but they
may they remain a very lethal force and
i think we would assess that probably
there are at least 2 000 hardcore isis
fighters in afghanistan now and of
course many of those come from the
prisons that were that were opened a few
a few days ago so that number is up and
is probably as high as it's ever been in
quite a while and that's going to be a
challenge for the taliban i believe in
the days ahead
thank you general uh two quick questions
there were about 500 afghan soldiers who
were protecting the perimeter did you
evacuate them and their families and
secondly um just on the airport uh now
that you've departed do you believe
it can uh take on civilian aircraft
pretty soon or would it require some
type of repair or expertise
sure so the best of my knowledge which
is actually pretty good i believe we
brought out all the afghan military
forces who were partnered with us to
defend the airfield and their family
members i believe that that has been
accomplished
we need the airport to be operational
and we need the airport to be
operational quickly for civilian you
know for civilian traffic so we're going
to do everything we can to uh
to help with that let me give an example
one of the things we did not
demilitarize as we left were those
pieces of equipment that are necessary
for airport operations such as a fire
truck some of the front end loaders
things like that we left that we left
that equipment so that is available uh
to allow that airport to get back and
get operating as soon as possible and
and it needs to get operating as soon as
possible
louis uh general today is august 30th
and the deadline had repeatedly been
said that it was going to be august 31st
um do you think that there may be some
people who had some false hope that they
had at least one more day before this
happened and can you explain the
tactical decision as to why you
completed this mission on the 30th as
opposed to the thursday
sure so it's actually the 31st in
afghanistan as we take a look what day
of the week what day of the month it is
this is the 30th here 31st in
afghanistan so we actually went out on
the 31st not the 30th if you look at
afghan time
look there's a lot of heartbreak
associated with this departure we did
not get everybody out that we wanted to
get out but i think if we stayed another
10 days louie we wouldn't have gotten
everybody out that we wanted to get out
and there still would have been people
who would have been disappointed with
that it's a it's a tough situation but i
want to emphasize again that simply
because we have left that doesn't mean
the opportunities for both americans
that are in afghanistan that want to
leave and uh and afghans who want to
leave they will not be denied that
opportunity i think our department of
state is going to work that very hard in
the days and weeks ahead
courtney uh just one clarification
general mckenzie it's courtney cubie
from nbc news
so were there any evacuees left at the
airport when the last military flight
left
there were no evacuees left at the
airport when the u.s last flight left
corner thank you and then just on the
taliban you know you've talked about
their pragmatic ways of operating with
the us military here do you see a role
for the u.s military to have open
conversations with the taliban even
potential coordination
going forward in particular
with this
growing and now accentuated
threat from isis
well i'll tell you my my dealing with
the taliban and
my the dealings of my commanders on the
ground with the taliban
revolved around our determination to
execute this operation and the very flat
statement we made to them but if we you
know if you challenge us we're going to
hurt you and i think they recognize that
and for their own purposes this is
something they wanted to have happen too
i would i i can't foresee the way future
coordination but between us would go uh
i would leave that for for some future
date i will simply say that they wanted
us out
we wanted to get out with our people and
we went with our and with our friends
and partners and so for that short
period of time our issues are
our view of the world was congress it
was the same finally i do believe the
taliban is going to have their hands
full with isis k and they let a lot of
those people out of prisons and now
they're going to be able to reap what
they sowed
tara
tara cop with defense one
can you assure the american public that
every single u.s service member is now
out of afghanistan
every single u.s service member is now
out of afghanistan i can say that with
100 certainty carla um
really quickly just to clarify um you
mentioned 123 000
out of afghanistan earlier this morning
we heard 122. so can we assume that that
was a thousand afghans that came out in
these some of these final flights and
then have a quick follow
we brought about a thousand afghans i
think
over 1500 out in the last 24 hours or so
the exact number i'm sure is probably
that that computation is probably going
to change a little bit in the days ahead
i don't think it's going to change much
but yes we brought a number of afghans
out here at the very end and then sir
how would you
characterize
this evacuation mission because on the
one hand 123 000 people got out on the
other hand of course you have you lost
13 marines
more than 100 afghans died and there are
still potentially tens of thousands sivs
p1s p2s and others that wanted to get
out that did not get out as you said so
how would you characterize this mission
well first of all the 11 marines the
soldier and the sailor that we lost i
will never forget that that will that
will be with me and i know every other
commander involved for the rest of our
lives we've all lost we've all lost
people before and it's never an easy
thing
you would like to bring out everybody
that wanted to come out we're not able
to do that situation wouldn't allow it i
think we did a very good job of getting
everybody that we could get that we
could get out given the unique change
the challenges of the tactical situation
on the ground the fact that really not
if not all americans wanted to leave
their americans for a variety of reasons
want to stay for a while i think we'll
go back and they'll have the opportunity
to uh they'll have the opportunity to
revisit that and come out if they want i
think it's just important to note that
we shouldn't look on this as the end of
that engagement about people in
afghanistan i am confident that that
engagement is going to continue through
a variety of venues and it won't just be
the united states that's going to be
engaged on this i think our
international partners are also going to
be very engaged on this as well going
forward
two more i'm afraid we'll go to the
phones again jack ditch
um thanks thanks general mackenzie i'm
i'm kind of curious just how american
citizens are going to be expected to get
to the airport and what the continuing
terror threat uh will be
just in the coming days and and what the
evacuation picture is going to look like
for them so i think that the the terror
threat's going to be very high and uh i
don't want to minimize that but i think
what we'll do is we will work with the
taliban and work with the next governor
of afghanistan afghanistan whatever his
characterization is going to be in order
to ensure that our citizens are
protected and that they have an
opportunity to uh to leave as you know
we still hold a variety of significant
leverage over whatever future government
exists in kabul and i have no doubt that
the department of state will fully
exercise that leverage
do you have any confidence in their
ability to secure the city right now the
taliban
i think they're going to be challenged
to secure the city i do know this just
speaking purely practically as a
professional they helped us secure the
airfield not perfectly but they they
gave it a very good effort and it was
actually significantly uh significant
significantly helpful to us particularly
here at the end last question for today
megan
sorry this is megan myers at military
times are there any u.s aircraft still
doing um over flights of afghanistan
either kabul or otherwise looking out
for potential threats
so as we have said for quite a while we
always reserve the opportunity to go
after in the ct around the
counter-terrorism realm al qaeda and
isis when those targets prevent present
themselves so we will always retain the
ability to do that
okay that's about all the time we have
general uh any concluding thoughts you
might want to add
john it's been a it's been a long day
and uh much longer actually for our
forces that are coming out
uh the operation has gone smoothly so
far and i just look forward to
look forward to recovering the force
completely getting everybody home
thank you general thanks for your time
thank you all have a nice afternoon
we've been listening in with hungry